the price of natural gas has increased
nearly 20 percent in the last year we've
all experienced this increase at the gas
pump and grocery stores envy energy the
sponsors of this next segment are here
to help let's welcome antoine tillman
he's the vice president of customer
operations welcome to the show thank you
thank you so how has the rise of natural
gas prices affected nv energy well as
everyone may or may not know our our
power plants are powered by natural gas
so those prices then impact the the way
we supply and and produce power which is
then transferred over to our customers
that information or i'm sorry that comes
through as a pass-through cost so that
20 percent you mentioned is coming
through um in our rates it's got a
trickle-down effect that happens here so
how are you helping your customers save
money what are you guys doing well the
most
important thing is conservation so we
have um a lot of information we have our
powershift which is we have what we call
a bundle and that bundle comes out they
help people we help our customers to
save save power um by lowering their
usage and is that with the the power
shift bundle is that these the smart
thermostat that you guys offer yes it's
one of the tools that we offer okay tell
me more about that what's the smart
thermostat why should everyone get one
so a smart thermostat i myself have one
and what it does is it enables you to
set your thermostat and forget it
because when you try to play thermos
you're trying to play the thermostat
you're messing with it okay so that's
not the best thing the smart thermostats
know how to do it very well so at me at
home constantly changing my thermostat
when i go to bed when i'm like that
that's the bad way
oh you just gave me a look too like
don't be doing that not good what about
we're in some hard times right here what
about financial assistance for people
out there yes so we do have we have our
project reach program
we also help with there's a state rand
program and we can help our customers to
get to those funds
so it's very important that they contact
us in the energy.com we're here to help
so very very important we we have many
tools that can help them someone or
everyone watching right now what are a
couple of things we can do i go home
tonight what are some things i can do in
my house to lower my energy costs so
again one thing during the winter months
68
so keep your thermostat at 68 that smart
thermostat
okay and it's your comfort zone so so
remember that's your comfort zone
keeping your water heater if you have a
gas or electric water heater at 120 and
there's other things that you can do um
like
using a blanket instead of turning up
the heat so there's many things and
again contacting the energy we can
really walk you through that and help
you with those i love it so many ways to
save money thank you so much antoine we
appreciate it okay i'm gonna get myself
a smart thermostat now just because that
look you gave me i'm gonna get myself
one thank you to envy energy for
sponsoring this segment visit
envyenergy.com
forward slash here to help for more
information mercedes over to you